hey this is preshtalwalkar
you visit a shrine that has three
temples in a magical pond
before you visit a temple you have to
swim in the pond
the path you take involves swimming in
the pond to get to the first temple
swimming in the pond to get to the
second temple and then swimming in the
pond to get to the third temple
each time you swim in the pond the
number of flowers you are carrying
magically triples
you place an equal number of flowers at
each temple you visit
and at the very end you have no flowers
remaining
the problem is what is the least number
of flowers you could have started with
to be specific you start with the
positive number of flowers and you place
a whole number of flowers at each temple
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
we will solve the problem algebraically
imagine you start with x flowers and you
leave y flowers at each temple
let's keep track of how many flowers you
have at each part of the trip
you start out with x flowers
when you swim in the pond the number of
flowers you have triples to 3x
you then leave y flowers at the first
temple which leaves you with three x
minus y flowers
you then swim in the pond
which triples the number of flowers you
have to 9x minus 3y
you'll leave y flowers at the second
temple which leaves you with 9x minus 4y
flowers
you then swim in the pond once more
which triples the number of flowers you
have to 27x minus 12y
you leave y flowers at the third temple
and you have 27x minus 13y flowers
of course at the very end you have no
flowers
this leads to the equation 27x minus 13y
equals 0.
so x equals 13 divided by 27 times y
we need the number of flowers you place
to be a whole number
the least value for y would be 27
which means that you started with 13
flowers
in fact this is the solution
we will verify this numerically
so if we start out with 13 flowers we
swim in the pond and that triples to 39.
we then leave 27 flowers at the first
temple which leaves us with 12 flowers
this triples to be 36.
we leave 27 flowers at the second temple
which leaves us with 9 flowers
this triples when we swim in the pond to
be 27 we then leave those 27 flowers at
the final temple which leaves us with
zero flowers
so that's the solution of this problem
now interestingly enough
the kind of mathematics involved in this
problem can actually be applied to
financial products
we can reinterpret the problem as an
example of an annuity
which is a financial instrument that has
equal payments at regular intervals
the number of flowers we place at each
temple y flowers could be considered
having equal payments at regular
intervals
imagine we take a loan out for x dollars
every year we pay off y dollars of the
loan
but each year the amount of debt that we
have remaining triples we have an
interest rate of 200 percent
if we had this kind of problem in each
temple we imagine visiting one temple in
a year
this would exactly lead us to the same
algebraic problem of paying off a debt
in three years
in which we have an equal payment of y
every year and the outstanding debt
triples
at the very end we would want our debt
to be zero
the mathematics of annuities can be
generalized so let's imagine we didn't
know anything about this problem and we
just approached it as an annuity
here's how it would work in terms of
time intervals
we start out at the first interval where
we take a loan of x dollars
after one year
our loan will increase by an outstanding
loan rate and interest rate of i percent
so we multiply x times one plus i
percent
after the first year we make a fixed
payment of y dollars which decreases the
balance of our outstanding loan by y
dollars now comes the part
where in the second year
we have an interest on the amount of
loan that's remaining so we multiply
these amounts by one plus i
this is like dipping into the pond and
having everything magically grow by one
plus i
so we multiply one plus i times both
terms and this is what we end up with
we then pay an amount y
and we subtract that on the outstanding
loan which then gets increased by one
plus i in the next period
so this pattern can continue and we can
imagine paying this off until n years
we end up with a formula that involves a
geometric series
we then have one final payment of y
which then changes the subscript on the
geometric series
and we now want our loan to be paid off
in n years so we need this to be equal
to zero
we can simplify this formula by using
the sum
of a geometric series up to n minus one
this is the formula that we end up with
and this can be used for any annuity
where you take out x dollars you have an
interest rate of i and you have n
periods
in the magical pond
we started out we had three different
temples so we had three different
periods
and between each temple we had to swim
in the pond and the number of flowers we
had tripled which is an interest rate of
200 percent
we can substitute these values into our
annuity formula
and notice we end up with exactly the
same equation of 27x minus 13y equals
zero
this is an alternate way of solving the
problem and it's a way to see how this
problem relates to financial products
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description